[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans sur ce
clic les ondes électromagnétiques
imaginons une particule qui possède une
charge électrique
de par sa charge la particule génère
autour d'elle un champ électrique ce
champ électrique est statique il ne
varie pas au cours du temps du fait que
la charge reste immobile mais imaginons
maintenant qu'on accélère cette charge
de sorte à la mettre en mouvement au
moment de l'accélérer la particule va
acquérir une certaine vitesse d'après la
relativité restreinte
cette vitesse que vient d'acquérir la
particule entraîne l'apparition d'un
champ magnétique autour d'elle mais les
champs électriques et magnétiques sont
intimement liés
ils sont les deux facettes d'un seul et
même objet le champ électromagnétique et
ils vont par conséquent interagir l'un
avec l'autre en particulier le champ
magnétique qui vient d'apparaître va
perturber le champ électrique
cette perturbation du champ électrique
va à son tour venir perturber le champ
magnétique de proche en proche
petit à petit les champs électriques et
magnétiques vons influencé et variés
l'un après l'autre perturbations après
perturbations de cette façon le
mouvement qu'on a infligé à la particule
va se répercuter dans tout l'espace
petit à petit se propageant à la vitesse
de la lumière à travers les champs
électriques et magnétiques
c'est ce phénomène qu'on appelle une
onde électromagnétique
en fonction de l'accélération de la
particule qui la génère une onde
électromagnétique va être plus ou moins
énergétiques
on peut ainsi classifier les ondes en
plusieurs catégories d'énergie en
fonction de la fréquence à laquelle s
docile on y trouve notamment la lumière
visible avec les différentes couleurs de
l'arc en ciel
mais pas seulement les infrarouges les
ultraviolets les micro ondes les rayons
x les ondes radio ou encore les rayons
gamma toutes ces ondes que l'on ne peut
pas voir avec nos yeux sont pourtant
elle aussi des ondes électromagnétiques
la grande majorité de ces rayonnements
nous est invisible mais avec nos
technologies actuelles il est possible
de concevoir des caméras spéciales et
des instruments de mesure de sorte à les
détecter ou à les émettre
c'est ce qui est exploité pour les fours
à micro-ondes les télécommunications et
autres transmission à distance mais
aussi l'astronomie et les télescopes
spatiaux
les astronomes observent l'univers avec
différents types d'ondés
car on peut ainsi sans faire une image
beaucoup plus large et détaillé comparé
à ce qu'on peut voir en se restreignant
uniquement la lumière visible dans la
nature
les ondes électromagnétiques sont
présentes partout dès lors qu des
particules chargées s'agite change de
vitesse ou de direction elle génère de
telles sondes qui vont se propager dans
l'univers notamment tous les objets qui
possède une température et met de tel
rayonnement
pour comprendre il est nécessaire de se
plonger à l'échelle microscopique
ici la température d'un objet correspond
à l'agitation des atomes mais les atomes
sont composés de deux parties un noyau
de charge électrique positive et un
nuage d'électrons de charge négative en
s'agitant les atomes vont faire vibrer
leur nuage électronique
ceux ci se comporte un peu comme s'ils
étaient reliés au noyau par un élastique
en vibrant toutes ces charges
électriques sont donc constamment en
train d'accélérer et de changer de
direction
les atomes vont ainsi émettre des ondes
électromagnétiques qui sont d'autant
plus énergétique que la température de
l'objet est élevé le corps humain par
exemple dont la température est
d'environ 37 degrés celsius est en
permanence en train d'émettre des
rayonnements infrarouges
ces ondes ne sont pas visibles par nos
yeux on ne voit pas les autres humains
brillé mais on peut les détecter avec
des caméras thermiques
une particularité très intéressantes des
ondes électromagnétiques
est ce qu'on appelle leur polarisation
comme on l'a vu précédemment les nuages
électronique au sein des atomes se
comporte un peu comme s'ils étaient
reliés au noyau par un élastique
quand les atomes sont agités les nuages
électroniques vont vibrer autour des
noyaux dans toutes les directions et les
ondes qui sont générés et vont avoir une
forme très chaotique
on dit que ce type d'onde n'est pas
polarisé imaginons qu'on envoie une onde
de cette forme sur une particule chargé
sous son passage la particule va subir
une force car elle interagit avec les
champs électriques et magnétiques qui
composent le monde
elle va alors se mettre à vibrer de la
même façon que l'undd et donc de la même
façon que les atomes qui l'ont générée
c'est de cette façon par exemple que le
soleil est en mesure de réchauffer
l'atmosphère terrestre
depuis des millions de kilomètres sa
chaleur se transmet depuis sa surface
jusqu'à notre atmosphère
par le biais des ondes
électromagnétiques qui se propage dans
le vide mais dont certaines situations
il est possible de faire vibrer les
atomes d'une façon beaucoup plus
contrôlés au lieu de prendre des
trajectoires chaotique les nuages
électroniques vont alors vibrer de trois
façons possibles pour comprendre
imaginons une bille posé sur une table
et qui serait relié un clou à l'aide
d'un élastique très tendu imaginons
qu'on lance la bille avec des vitesses
différentes
on observe que sa trajectoire va le plus
souvent formés des ellipses et
quelquefois des lignes droites ou des
cercles parfaits au sein des atomes les
nuages électroniques sont attirés par
les noyaux de la même façon que la bille
est attiré vers le cloud ainsi ils vont
eux aussi pouvoir vibrer de ces trois
façons possibles et de la sorte générer
des ondes électromagnétiques très propre
avec une forme bien régulière et
répétitive
on dit que ces ondes sont polarisées
avec une polarisation rectiligne
elliptique ou circulaires les antennes
radio par exemple font osciller des
atomes selon l' axe de l'antenne
elle génère ainsi des ondes très propre
qui oscille de façon régulière et avec
une polarisation rectiligne
en ce qui concerne la lumière sa
polarisation n'est pas directement
visibles à l'oeil nu
en effet nos yeux ne sont sensibles qu'à
l'intensité lumineuse mais pas à la
direction des champs électriques et
magnétiques
cela dit c'est une propriété très
importante qui va influencer la façon
dont la lumière interagit avec les
objets il existe en particulier des
filtres qui permettent d'absorber
certaines polarisation plutôt que
d'autres on appelle ces filtres des
polariseur ils sont notamment utilisés
pour la technologie du cinéma 3d où on
peut ainsi projetés deux images
simultanément avec deux polarisation
différentes et concevoir des lunettes
avec des verres polarisés heures qui ne
vont faire passer qu'une seule des deux
polarisation et donc une seule des deux
images pour chaque oeil
enfin les ondes électromagnétiques étant
des ondes
elle évolue dans l'espace et réagissent
avec la matière selon des phénomènes
bien particulier tout d'abord comme
toutes les ondes
elles s'ajoutent les unes avec les
autres en particulier si on superpose
deux bosses on va obtenir une bosse deux
fois plus grande alors que si on
superpose une onde avec son exact opposé
les deux vont parfaitement s'annuler de
sorte à n'avoir plus aucune longue
finale on appelle ce principe de
superposition des ondes les
interférences les interférences des
ondes sont notamment à la base du
phénomène de diffraction qu'on observe
quand une onde rencontre un petit
obstacle ou qu'elle passe à travers une
fente très fine
ensuite comme on l'a vu précédemment
lorsqu'elle traverse un milieu
transparent composé d'atomes l'ondé
électromagnétique va générer une force
sur les nuages électronique de sorte à
les mettre en mouvement
ces vibrations au sein des atomes vont
elles mêmes émettre des ondes qui se
propage dans toutes les directions et
qu'ils partagent à peu près les mêmes
caractéristiques que l'undd initial
ainsi même si on les clercs selon une
certaine direction le milieu va produire
de la lumière qui se diffuse dans toutes
les directions
c'est ce qu'on appelle la diffusion
l'atmosphère de la terre est un très bon
exemple pour illustrer le phénomène de
diffusion l'atmosphère en elle-même n'a
pas vraiment de couleurs c'est un milieu
transparent mais le soleil envoie
constamment des rayonnements
électromagnétiques vers notre planète et
en particulier de la lumière blanche qui
est composé de toutes les couleurs de
l'arc en ciel au passage de ses ondes
les atomes qui composent l'air vont se
mettre à vibrer et ainsi à diffuser la
lumière dans toutes les directions
mais le phénomène de diffusion est
d'autant plus puissant que l'undd est
énergétique
les teintes rouge jaune et verte
correspondent à des ondes relativement
faible tandis que les teintes bleues
possède davantage d'énergie ce sont donc
les ondes de couleur bleue qui vont
davantage faire vibrer les électrons et
donc se diffuser et c'est pour cette
raison que le ciel nous apparaît bleus
pour finir lorsqu'on envoie une onde
électromagnétique sur un matériau par
exemple de l'eau une partie de l'ong va
continuer son chemin dans la matière
tandis que l'autre partie va rebondir
dans l'autre sens on dit que l'undd et
réfractée dans un sens et réfléchie dans
l'autre sens
d'une part commençons par nous pencher
sur le phénomène de réflexion quand on
en voit de la lumière sur un matériau
conducteur comme le métal à la surface
d'un miroir certains électrons à la
surface ne sont pas liées aux atomes
c'est ce qui donne au métal sa capacité
à conduire l'électricité
mais au passage de l'ondé lumineuse les
champs électromagnétiques qui la
composent vont venir mettre en mouvement
ces électrons libres de cette façon des
courants électriques vont se former à la
surface et ses courants reproduisent
parfaitement la forme de l'undd
incidente les mouvements de ces
électrons à la surface du métal vont à
leur tour générer une onde similaire à
l'undd incidente mais qui se propagent
des deux côtés de la surface en eau
cette onde correspond à londres réfléchi
quand on se regarde dans un miroir
c'est cette onde qui est générée par les
courants électriques dans le métal que
l'on va voir et en bas l'undd générés
par les courants électriques et
parfaitement opposé à l'undd incidente
les deux vont donc interférer de sorte à
annuler longue initial d'autre part la
portion d'onde qui a réussi à traverser
la surface de l'eau semble bizarrement
se propageait dans une direction
légèrement différente et surtout se
déplaçait plus lentement
c'est ce qu'on appelle la réfraction
la réfraction est un phénomène complexe
qui est dû encore une fois à la
superposition de plusieurs bombes au
passage de l'undd incidente les atomes
et leur nuage électroniques vont se
mettre à vibrer dans l'eau de sorte à
émettre des nouvelles sondes qui vont
s'additionner à l'ong de départ mais ces
nouvelles ondes sont légèrement décalée
par rapport à l'undd incidente et ceci
va avoir pour effet de ralentir le
faisceau lumineux dans sa globalité
il est important de comprendre que la
vitesse de la lumière en soi n'a pas
changé les champs électromagnétiques
réagissent toujours à la même vitesse et
chacune des ondes générées par les
atomes se déplace à la vitesse de la
lumière
mais le faisceau lumineux qui prend en
compte la somme de toutes les ondes
ralenti bel et bien du fait de toutes
ces superpositions un faisceau de
lumière se propage donc moins vite dans
certains matériaux que dans le vide et
il est possible pour des particules de
dépasser la vitesse de la lumière ou
plutôt de dépasser la vitesse de
propagation d'un faisceau lumineux au
sein d'un matériau à la façon du bang
qui se produit lorsqu'un avion dépasse
la vitesse du son ce phénomène entraîne
l'apparition d'un flash de lumière
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'effet
tcherenkov et c'est une méthode utilisée
aujourd'hui par les scientifiques pour
détecter les neutrinos
[Musique]
m